let me say let me say this though I do I
do
I am sorry like I am sorry that it ended
like it all ended it came to this it
came that I am sorry when I release one
of the reasons I would also release our
sorry deleted the text messages was like
I said I was having a complete breakdown
I was breathing into a paper bag and all
sudden I took a step back and I was I
was like Kaelyn is feeling this way
right now probably and that killed me
and I was like I was like I believe I
did what I'm feeling right now I just
did to somebody else and that hurts and
that sucked and so that's why I did
suddenly take the text messages down and
I did have you know a moment to step
back from everything like what did I
just do I had to have that moment and so
that was hard and I am sorry that it
hurt her the way it did it is something
that you know I wish I didn't come to
that I really do one thing that was said
from Kaelyn and I've actually heard this
too is that you were talking or
considering about releasing these text
messages from the moment you saw that
episode air because it wasn't what you
believe to be the truth and you
consulted with people you talked to
people even even the people who were
actually involved Caitlyn yourself and
Dean said you talked to him as well so
what made you ultimately say you know
what against what everybody else is
saying cuz it seemed like everybody told
you no you said yes I'm going to release
them yeah so I think Caitlyn use the
word pre or she said yes premeditate so
yeah Kalyn you know cheese word
premeditated and premeditated I was just
a fancy way of saying you know I thought
really hard about because I did I it was
such a hard decision for me
that night when I release those text
messages I really was I was breathing
into a paper bag like it was incredibly
difficult for me and a decision like
that you do reach out for advice and
especially advice for people who have
been in situations like me and in
bachelor nation and it what a lot of
people they didn't even really say no
don't do it they were like if you do
this know what's the consequences or
that kind of thing like that's and I did
reach out and some you know there were a
few that were like
you have like the things she's saying
like you have to do it like yeah I don't
see how any other choice and so when
people say you know why did you was
premeditated or whatever I it was such a
hard decision for me I wanted to reach
out and I wanted to talk to other people
and I wanted to see if anybody else had
any other ideas I want to see if there
was any other avenue I could take and at
the end of the day as hard as it was I
felt like that was the only thing I
could do to get truth my truth out there
and because I I didn't know a lot of
things she was saying when I was down
there had I know she was saying that I
was silencing her and all these things I
would have addressed it on the beach
with her but I had no idea she was
saying those things and so when I
watched it I was shook I was shocked
it was just I couldn't believe it I just
couldn't believe she was saying the
thing she was saying one of the big
things I can take away from this is I
found out really fast who my real
friends are and sometimes bachelor
nation they they'll they'll say think
privately I had a lot of people
especially people you know even people
sitting in that panel at the Reunion
they reached out and they said you know
I probably would have done kind of what
you said like I probably would have done
what you did like I've never been that
position but man I don't know what I
would do
but then you know in public they they
don't they don't they're for you and
they don't they don't support you and
real fast I found out who my real
friends are and I won't forget like I
you know I know who now I'm putting my
energy into in the friendships I'm gonna
put my energy into because a lot of
people not only in bachelor nation but
in general you know I'm sure in real
life too like if it doesn't I think self
serving is the right word if it doesn't
help them in any way you know they often
distance themselves and I had a lot of
friends distance themselves but I also
had a lot daddy honestly I'm closer than
ever with and yeah I won't forget that
for sure
you